as long as we're talking shake your
moneymaker we're gonna do hard to handle
it's the only cover on the album yeah
did you guys cover this right from the
beginning and was this something that
you guys love you know we it was my I
mean I wanted to do the song you know
cuz I oldest reading to still to me is
the greatest R&B soul singer that ever
was and luckily for I mean the cool
thing about hard-to-handle at the time
was it was a b-side for him so it wasn't
like I was singing these arms of mine or
you know some people that song yeah you
know I mean it was like for us being
from Georgia Otis's from Georgia it was
you know we kind of came full circle and
a song like that's intimidating isn't it
in the sense that Otis Redding that's
his song and then when you go to do it
you know you're gonna be compared to
every time every time I sing it I always
know Otis is the greatest I always know
I'll never do it as great but I don't
think we attempted to redo it I mean if
anything Georgia Cooley is was the one
who's like oh we should make it a little
like walk this way you know it's right
in the time and stuff yeah you got you
how to put your spin on it yeah and make
it more rock and roll than a than a Stax
single or b-side or whatever so we're
going back in time going back to I'm
just what you'll hear and when you go
see the boys and yep this is the only
cover from that album
[Music]
say
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
sangman logic you know calls her mama
I'm sure our defender now
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
sangman loud you can't cause a mama I'm
sure I do now
[Music]
[Music]
still got you
[Music]
[Music]
let me la chica no calls a mama I'm sure
hard
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
saying let me logic it'll cause a mama
I'm sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's beautiful beautiful